So, the Python Standard Library suggests that the
function open returns an object of the file
type. Now this word object is really interesting
because we have seen it before. Remember the time
when we were drawing squares using the class
Turtle? We were writing lines of code like this.
This meant that Brad was an object or
instance of the class Turtle. Similarly, when we write
lines like this, which is quotes equal to open
file location, and the file, in our case, was
a movie quotes file. We are saying that quotes
is an object or an instance of file. Now let's
think for a moment, what happens when we run
this line of code. When we do run this
line of code, a function called _init_ is called
from inside the class Turtle. And what that does is
that it creates space in memory for the object Brad. Now in the case of open,
even though on surface it looks like we
are merely calling a function, and that there
is no class involved. If you look deep down inside the code for how open was
actually implemented inside Python. We will find that
open, in turn, is calling some init-like function
to create an object of file. All right, that's enough
jargon for now. We will talk about instances and objects a
little bit later in the course. For now, we can rejoice
in the fact that part one of profanity checker is done.